what is happening there reject
nation we finally got ourselves a
moon night official trailer coijondro back on the
channel i'm here i'm alive i'm excited our marvel
comics expert right here we're counting
on you to give a the best trailer review
afterwards luckily moon knight isn't dense
or complicated or has gone through a series
of cancellations and myriad of writers it's a
very linear character easy to explain all right
you have to wrap it up in like two minutes two
minutes whole character watch time to worry
about it right i know my place this is content
all right we talk slowly and calmly there's
only so much we can learn on wikipedia before
filming as you guys know i love wikipedia hosts
hello and welcome to staying
awake i have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference between my waking life
i'm looking forward to this already yes
you're bloody useless stevie stephen
hope you find it thanks
oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark why did you call me mark
that's your stance that's
difficult oh it's in your head this
wow um shadow of the moon night
how nice
i love how they even change their colors to it
you know man uh is it this is the shadow of moon
knight did you catch like there was he walked
under the light and the the crescent moon like
that's oh that's my that's one of my favorite ones
from any trailer this this uh this is is it too
early to say that this might turn into my favorite
one of the marvel that's not just me like talking
hype that is that is like oh my god that is
exactly my kind of show right there i think that's
the best trailer the darkness the supernatural
elements the variety of performance by oscar
isaac because yeah this confirms that he is going
to be we were like speculating before the trailer
started of will they get like different actors
for some of the personalities which one seems to
be the dominant personality though in this trailer
there seems to be one stephen scene dominant but
i think that's a mislead because mark is in the
comic book is the dominant one mercenary that gets
taken out by bushmaster yes and i assume that's
a mislead on purpose because it's not a known
character so maybe steven is who we identify with
in the first episode yeah and therefore you think
he's this more posh well-to-do guy and then maybe
the second episode they introduced the cabbie
and we've got a character you're like wait why is
he now this guy and like we slowly find mark maybe
like uncover his true self yeah what i'm loving
about it is like how psychological it is like
it's gonna deal with the fact of how this kind of
plays on uh disassociative identity disorder and
the way how they visually represent that through
like the cracks and the mirrors and the different
presences and the hallways and stuff like
that was so cool to behold and oscar i think
the cadence like that the flavor of the edit
which i hope the show follows with man john
what was your favorite part about it oh man just
the the whole vibe and atmosphere really i mean
i like that this movie this trailer played more
like a movie trailer than a tv show trailer and
you know it is a six episode contained series with
the option of going beyond that and i think that
this is the perfect way to just hook everybody for
yeah the kind of ride we're into it looks like the
kind of thing that's going to be very fraught
and very paranoid and i love anything that has
that quality where you know you've got flashes
and echoes and what's real which reflection
is actually mine you know ethan hawk looks
sinister as you know i wonder if he's conscious
himself no no like like a i i said country but
someone working directly for him like the voice
of country like he's okay i don't think he's the
actual god but explain that a little bit for them
so basically mark spector is killed in an incident
as a mercenary xcia and he is dragged into an
egyptian temple where he isn't actually alive or
dead he's basically revived in what he thinks is
serving the god of konchu he is the moon's
knight which is the egyptian god of the night and
basically the powers he has yeah and that's the
difference between him in batman so like batman
is striking fear because he wants to avenge
his parents he's in love with the concept of
vengeance so it's not about a specific vengeance
it's vengeance incarnate which is what makes this
character so interesting he wears white as a
threat he wants you to see him he believes in
hurting those that deserve it and it's unilateral
it's anyone that deserves it so he's striking fear
for this god and he doesn't really have a power
set like in some continuities as the moon wanes
some of his powers increase like if there are some
moon thailands i don't know if they're going to do
that but konshu himself is a voice that speaks to
him and there's some continuities where the voices
in his head are catalyzed by khanshu there's
also some where konju saw him as a young child
wait until he was old enough and then made him his
mercenary like it was all faded i don't know which
ones are gonna know i'm assuming they'll do the
one where it's later in life he gets activated
that causes the voices to materialize there's two
main voices and then there's two supporting voices
um there's the inner child and the uh mr knight
which i think will come in later and then there's
jake as well as stephen and i think we're gonna
get those very early on like i said i think mark
will be uh developed the main human self will come
i don't know if anything that made sense i think
i know i i know the anxiety of like because
i'm very interested as i was catching we've
done more than wikipedia like i was catching
on to let's catch up where you're saying you
said conscious i'm like okay there might be some
people who don't know what's going on they're like
we got all this egyptian imagery in here it
looks like like the trailer might have you
believing that he gets it like at the museum
artifact spot but you see i think you see a
pyramid at one point it was kind of moving
by fast so i imagine that his personality
was eventually at one point in egypt and then
he's probably just going to like here are some
authentic artifacts at this museum that are being
called to me in some ways right like some people
when the teaser trailer came out what do you think
some people were saying that looks like a werewolf
some people were saying looks like anubis i mean
they've said that egyptology is going to be a big
part of the show and so in that breath i would
imagine maybe something like that but moon
knight's origin also ties in with the werewolf by
night which i would just be so excited to see them
breach further into especially because this is
also being billed as a scarier more horror-centric
series so i mean for for my geeky heart i would
be thrilled by that although something a little
more egyptian would fit as well you know what i
really thought with ethan hawk it's not exactly
the same thing there were vibes about parts of
this trailer that were making me reminisce on
the first blade movie and steven dorff's like the
the villainous president that he had there there
was parts about ethan hawk that i was thinking of
i say that complimentary wise his blade that is
like i actually i love that first movie started
marvel and then you know we were thinking about
the future of like a darker avengers set like the
midnight suns and having blade possibly come into
the mix here and maybe blade might cap like he had
a voiceover cameo in eternals post credit scene
spoilers by the way sorry i don't give a heads up
but yeah yeah that came in here and i was like it
would make more sense for even blaze to appear
here if they're like teasing his appearances as
guest starring how neat would that be in the
revived term i could totally see blade guest
starring in this show and spoilers for no way home
daredevil also allows this could set the precedent
for a dark show to allow daredevil to be as dark
since it is canon to the netflix show which is
much darker than the mcu this would allow that
universe to exist alongside the mcu you can do a
marvelous you can do something with daredevil like
that more ultra violence that's one of the things
i was really gravitated towards about this trailer
was when you're hearing moon knight when you're
learning about him you're like wow this sounds
like this would have to be a really dark almost
like closer to the netflix shows than any of the
other disney plush shows that we've gone in so far
other than some you know certain shots that look
really pop in the colors in that mcu fashion for
the most part the tone the mood the atmosphere of
it i want to get a better sense of the atmosphere
honestly because i'm like we got like that cool
music that i thought complemented the trailer well
but i do want to get a better sense of like what
will some of these scenes feel like and so far i'm
loving it can i say like the directing in this
uh two of my buddies i love these guys to death
justin and aaron are are two of the best directors
working and i'm honored to call them friends
they make that's the only reason you're
recommending this i'm yes i'm only here for them
so uh if you haven't seen spring if you haven't
seen synchronics if you haven't seen the endless
check out their work the reason i think they suit
this so well is they do this insane existential
pondering this otherworldly this this atmospheric
tone that's going to suit this so well they're
like hp lovecraft vibes that i think are going to
really tie into how this mythology looks visually
yeah and both of these guys are they've done
everything on a set they've done every single job
on the set and now they're directing one of the
coolest most hard to discern characters so these
guys are going to be so hands on they're going to
make this their own and that's why i think this
looks so unique is justin and aaron are geniuses
and this is going to show for it so uh can we have
them on the channel for an interview i mean we'll
send them this link we'll be like hey justin here
yeah if they're your real friends they'll text
them watch this video and then they'll that's
true we'll test that yeah we'll see if that's
one way if you retweet this director's a moon
great guys i love you guys no pressure
i'm not no all right intimidated
well we're done here we're styling i think that
was your name yeah it was because if you've seen
spring the endless or synchronic which i recommend
you do in fact homework if you want to understand
moon knight check out their work also check
out the mirror's run the ellis run bendis's
runs and cabbage's art any of that stuff to
give you the flavor of this book you know
you don't have to feed the
whole cattle of all the time
it's been around since the 70s i gave
the taste it's a dump of information
jeff lemire subscribe if you're interested
you can leave your thoughts down below follow
coy because he knows crap some more
comics uh look guys we'll see you soon